yep
hunter biden has embarked on a full-time
career as an artist and some of his
paintings can cause six figures in a
statement his dealer george berguez
uh uh told insider it is an honor that
i'm able to represent hunter biden he's
a wonderfully gifted talent and fine
artist he has garnered a following of
collectors who appreciate
and see the intrinsic value of his work
biden 51 years old has been painting
since he was a young child and he told
arnett that he's
never had any formal training in his new
los angeles home biden reportedly
converted a three-car garage into an art
studio that includes a brick floor
and skylight prices for its artwork
range from seventy five thousand dollars
uh for work on paper to five hundred
thousand dollars for large
scale paintings who actually fully
believes this adam are you
you know what do you think about this
story here well i've already bought
three pieces
so it's uh i think he's a talented
artist i think hunter biden
is uh is the next picasso clearly it's
uh that's what's going on well
you know i think something for the first
thing that came to mind
when i heard that he's becoming an
artist it's that he's getting in on this
nft craze is that everyone out there is
an artist and they're doing nfts now
and half the people are like what the
hell's an nft and other half of the
people are basically saying it's the
next big
thing um but the next thing that i'm
thinking about that other than the nft
is i actually think that hunter biden
deserves to be on a list
that we have a running list going on
right now and that list that we've been
talking about for a few weeks now is
who are the biggest trolls out there we
put takashi 69
we put jake paul up there i think hunter
biden
smoking crack doing whatever business
he's doing
whether it's shady or undisclosed
whether whatever this artwork is going
on
i think he's actually just a troll and
he the media is obsessed with him
and uh i think he's doing a good job of
trolling however
i don't know where this artwork's going
i'm sure you have a very different
perspective on his artwork
look this there there's narratives have
purposes right
and there is a media narrative that is
trying to
um clean up the hunter biden image
in time for the midterm elections and
that's the narrative the narrative
around hunter biden
is the liberal side of the media the
mainstream media are trying to
uh you know adjust the image of hunter
biden
in time for the midterms that's all
that's going on here
that's the narrative so little things
like this
somebody's sitting around and says okay
this way the story will be
i love this sentence here he has
garnered a following of collectors who
appreciate and see the value of his work
from china from brazil i'll change it
this way from mexico
he's garnered a following arabia hang on
he's garnered a following of donors who
appreciate the value of getting close to
his father yeah
i changed two words in a sentence i mean
come on i
i think this is a narrative this is a
puff piece that's been put together
to help adjust his image in the face
of the facts that he himself is just
dumped in the lab i remember
i remember jerry tarkanian being
interviewed and saying
the shark he says your players get paid
unlv you know the old larry johnson
stacey augment
uh anthony and all those guys i see
augmented yeah that's right left-handed
guy
greg anthony gregory great team unlv
anthony once
went up against was it jordan he tried
to fight or kobe he went up against one
of those two guys greg anthony they went
into it
they got into it i think it was uh
anyways so jerry tarkinis being
interviewed and they said listen you're
paying your players
i'm not paying my places we followed the
guidelines of the ncaa
very strictly they said voices what do
you mean
he says how do you guys have big jewelry
listen
we follow the guidelines very strictly
period
and and the reporter keeps going but you
keep paying your places i'm not paying
the players so then
i'm obviously i have a lot of friends in
vegas and i've interviewed a lot of
random people who know a lot of people
in vegas who
bet and you know the unlv was known for
losing
that what do you call it the uh whatever
the spread was okay
they're favored by six somehow they lose
by five turnover at the end of the game
they were
great at dealing with donald trump they
controlled all of it right so
he said look it was a very simple
business model he says
they would go and have a job as a valet
for 30 minutes or whatever it was and
they would say stand over there
work valet and when the red car comes
you only get to value that red car so
they would go valley the red car that
would park in the tip would be a hundred
thousand dollar tim
he followed the guidelines strictly
you're allowed to get tested
yeah i'm just doing my make i make five
bucks an hour but i make a hundred
thousand tips right i get to keep the
car
yeah he seemed like a nice young man
took good care of my car
that's it how i tell me it's my business
people tip like that every day go ahead
imagine the one day somebody else goes
and gets the car
by accident oh my but they're gonna know
who tells you
because you would know grandmama if you
see lj you would know this guy's a
monster right is who he was anyways one
of the players on that team is a barber
now and he's at the
barber at the same place i go to and
he's got some crazy he was on the unlv
running 911 yeah he's a barber now and
he has some
he says listen as crazy as you think it
was it was a hundred times worse wow he
says he says the kind of stuff that we
were doing was ridiculous he says i've
never partied like that in my life
he says it was crazy to think things
were being done to us we were doing
stuff that shouldn't be
you're the best basketball team in the
country in college
nba team and you're the best and you're
the biggest nba team and you're in
college right so what's the moral this
year exactly
he's the moral district the moral the
story is he's not breaking any laws
okay which means if let's go
both ways let's go both right brain and
left brain
okay right brain says what what an
incredible artist
good for him leave him alone let him be
creative
you know his mind goes places and he
wants to put art he's creative you know
creative people when you smoke crack
your mind will go to different places
and then you can
i i had a friend of mine that would do
shrooms all the time and i used to love
having dinner with them because i would
say did you see that unicorn and he
would say no
i would walk him outside look up there's
a unicorn
and i would sing in the background
never-ending story
remember the movie i don't know what
grade one right he says man i missed the
unicorn i said no you got to see the
other one the flying dog
the flying dog right there and he would
buy naive guy
innocent you would have a blast you're
actually seeing it because he took that
many mushrooms he was
that and we would go he was on acid
maybe not much
it was both of them he would be the one
that would discriminate
[Music]
shakers shakers we would go there with
him and my friend armin who's no longer
with us anyways
so look if hunter wants to be creative
more power to him if he wants to be
creative you know you know sometimes
when you age
president bush started doing artwork
what he's doing money laundering come on
man he's just doing artwork right
right but on the other side is let's
just say this is a play to play type of
a model
okay let's say he is doing art where
people from other countries who are
you know powerful people from saudi
arabia all of a sudden buys one of his
art pieces for seven million dollars if
that happens
yeah and you don't speculate you are the
most naive person
i totally agree with you but i tell you
if it's selling for 50 grand 75 000 if
they're money laundering at that price
that's nothing no one's doing seventy
five thousand dollar money laundering
type of deal let me let me ask you that
i i knew this uh joe when i selected him
i i knew this was going to be a problem
i'll just find it amazing that we got
through eight years of this before it
blew up and you you know how hard it was
to keep a lid on this
i should have got an another nobel prize
for just keeping a lid on this one
was that obama clinton or obama
you know it's a problem if you don't
know no that's not no that was
clinton would be i don't really
understand this i think this
this article that was obama's you do a
way better clinton than obama you want
to give it another crack are you good
i i didn't let my brother get anywhere
near stuff like this remember
you're good on clever roger clinton not
obama obama can you do obama or no
change does anyone have change for a
dollar
no you sound like jerry scientific yeah
okay i can't remember him
okay what's the deal okay
okay you bring up actually a good point
here with your friend
um roger clinton that was clinton's
brother by the way a plus senator
clinton
c-minus on obama but you keep practicing
biz doc don't stop
i guess my bigger question i guess my
bigger question here is
how much sway good or bad
do the president's kids or family
members
actually have on the polls or votes
meaning the first lady melania dr
jill biden michelle they've got some
sway that's the first lady like they're
in but you know i don't know how much
pull the trump kids had i don't know how
much poll hunter biden has
or sasha and malia or roger clinton
i feel like all right where are we going
what's next i feel i feel like
every um how much president how much
pull do you have when you go to body
bodega
i don't mean pull i mean like in terms
of voting what are you talking
about i'm good i'm good you go to bodega
what happens things are good
you're dreaming you're not even keith's
son you're a friend yes
you're not anything in that it's not
like you own a part of it right
this is their son we i mean it's like
i'm
a hunter biting bro you want to get to
my dad i'm a contact away
i don't mean it like that clearly i mean
in terms of
10 for the big guys in terms of vote
yeah yeah no no that's my point in terms
of
you're right no like roger clinton i did
pull
votes yeah i didn't no i didn't say i
said polls not pull
i got it clearly you have pull i'm i'm
i'm chelsea clinton i'm a clinton
like slin's daughter i'm i i'm donald
trump jr yeah you want to get to the
the president i don't think i mean some
turns into the in the
actual votes people say you know i was a
clinton guy but i'm really not a fan
i think america rolls their eyes america
rolls her eyes at this stuff
i remember that's my point i remember um
jimmy carter had a brother billy and
he was when you do a jimmy carter no uh
and he was
he was a raging raging alcoholic with
issues
billy was yeah and jimmy carter made no
apologies for him he says look he needs
he's he needs to get his life together
like anybody else does
he gets off the airplane i think it was
air force one he gets off the airplane
on the tarmac
and you know there's a bathroom on the
plane but apparently he just walked
around behind a couple of those enormous
wheels and took a leak
on the tarmac and you can go look it up
that's some gangster [ __ ] right there
yeah and you know and the president
united states is
but his name was billy and so some
company
like played into his alcoholism and he
had a brand of beer it's called billy
beer
i have i have you know
uh you know back in the day had a friend
that used to collect
beer cans you know like trading cards
like rare beer cans and things like this
but it was um anyway billy beer man
so i i think i think by and large the
american population rolls their eyes
at it until it crosses over and
jared jared kushner crossed over he's
doing things in politics
so now this really matters and we get
big opinions on it hunter biden was
doing things on international stage
now we wake up and we don't let him get
by with it
so but i think he's right it's billy
brother billy beer
yeah billy beer yeah and take a look at
him close do you see the family
resemblance from a younger jimmy carter
of course i see it
and it's just like and you can also look
on there
urinates urinates you know underneath
air force one i saw that
i think at the end of the day i think
it's a good talking point especially for
your own
team oh hunter did this why did you look
that up
right here there it is it's just a walk
and talking to wikipedia
all right let's i just don't think it
moves the needle okay so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye